Cloud functions is an event-driven
serverless compute platform
learn how to use cloud functions to
create and scale event-driven apps in
the developing applications with Cloud
functions on Google Cloud course
hi everyone I'm Hansel with technical
curriculum developer at Google cloud in
this course you learn about Cloud
functions Google's serverless fully
managed functions as a service product
that lets you implement single purpose
function code that responds to http
requests and events from your Cloud
infrastructure this course is for
application developers Cloud Architects
and Cloud developers and other
individuals that are looking to learn
about Cloud functions and improve the
application development skills on Google
Cloud
through a series of video lectures and
Hands-On labs you'll learn about Cloud
functions
and recognize their benefits and use
cases in modern application development
upon completion of the course you will
understand how to build test and deploy
Cloud functions
in addition you will learn how to secure
and connect Cloud functions to resources
and Cloud databases and use best
practices with Cloud functions
let's get started